[Applause]
mark made a really interesting point
about the whole night
i think we're on the drive home uh with
colorblind miles miles is the guy that
does uh i can't believe we let him drive
it was high i believe they can't be
pilots stop sign yeah yeah
uh we found out miles who does all the
uh editing for the podcast
and uh color correction is uh colorblind
we found truly about this out
like truly failed colorblind tests we
found on google yeah yeah he's
completely
colorblind it is unbelievable but if
anyone ever says that we're ableist on
this podcast it's not true
well we've given him a [ __ ] job i
should fire his ass but he's still
working here and we gotta get him those
glasses
oh we'll give him a glasses we'll do it
live we'll have like an emotional
breakdown yeah oh those videos are great
it'll be amazing i mean it'll be
absolutely amazing yeah
um anyway point is we're riding back and
then and then uh mark goes um
this is a pretty significant um event
in recent history and i'm like why and
he goes uh
because i think this is what really
opens things up i go what are you
talking about like things are kind of
open he goes
yeah but this is the first indoor full
capacity event
that is uh
profited off of okay
okay the outdoor stuff you feel kind of
safe yeah right but like
the mouse is making money off of this
yeah this is disney
right so they're willing to put their
reputation
up to make money off of this fight right
and
what's interesting is
what moves things a lot of times in this
country is not necessarily morality it's
capitalism yes
so all these other places that are going
i don't know if we can be open i don't
know if we can hold these events you
know there's a liability here
they're going to go wait a minute
they're making money off of live events
why the [ __ ] are we not making money off
live events it's time for us to make
some [ __ ] money
yep and uh that is how you get the gears
grinding in terms of really opening
things up yep 100 and i even think
optically
having the people that were there on
camera without matt like someone like
tom brady
without a mask ocho cinco masked up
going to hug
masculist tom brady yeah which was like
but someone like tom brady is just like
a superhero
yeah society like and to see someone
like him in the stadium no mass just
yeah
i think optically it does a lot for like
huge the morale of
the country and we were sitting there
wondering if this was
uh all by design because the first like
four or five
fights were a chinese person
versus either an american or like anyone
else
yeah it was anybody else but it seemed
now i understand they have like a fight
academy in china and they're probably
trying to promote the sport in china and
this is not how they
wanted the night to go but it almost
looked like the world was beating up on
china
in the first event where people are back
in the stadiums like this is payback it
looked like payback
it really looked like [ __ ] payback
and i'm like are they doing this on
purpose
is this a promotional time i thought
they wanted china to win all the fights
because they
there's so much money in china yeah
there's two billion dollars to your
point to promote there capitalism moves
everything there's so many people there
i'm sure that was their intention
but it almost felt as if yeah one
chinese person won their fight i think
adam and that person wasn't even chinese
i think they were like mongolian yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] mongolian guy
yeah even way whatever whaley or
whatever is the one that thug rose
knocked the [ __ ] out
we thought she's going to beat beat that
she's nice bro she was great in the last
fight we were really
she's a savage that girl is absolutely
savage but thug rose
knocked her in her [ __ ] head with
that front kick yeah
and uh oh yeah it was absolutely amazing
but it's
just really cool to see it's really cool
to see it happen and you realize how
much
the fans do affect the sport like we
tricked ourselves in going oh it's
really
cool to hear what the coaches are saying
we were watching all those fights
without the fans and then you saw
the fans roaring after a strike and
you're like oh there's nothing like this
this is the energy this is what we pay
for right this is what we paid for to be
there live
and this is part of what we pay for to
watching
at our homes like when you watch the
world cup do you guys want to watch a
[ __ ] world cup without fans no no
[ __ ] you've been watching any of the
champions league games or premier league
games it's like
i want to hear the vooboo zelas or
whatever the [ __ ] i wanna hear all of it
yes and i really do think it impacts the
fighters and it impacts any athlete
playing in that setting bro i love that
we're still able to hear the coaches
though
yeah you could kind of hear him still
yeah the coaches yeah cause that was one
thing i enjoyed when the fans weren't
there
yeah man yeah sorry you know what i
realize is how much joe rogan
does for ufc in the sense that like him
and daniel cormier and who's the other
guy the other commentator
john is it john john and mick or
something like that yeah the three of
them when they have the reaction
whenever there's a knockout and joe's
grabbing both
three homies hanging out watching sports
and they happen to know the sport very
well
that's the way you want all your sports
to be commentated it's just that's the
exact reaction when one of us says i'm
funny we grab each other we slap each
other
go nuts that's like so much more
um accessible it makes the sports seem
that much more supposed to be
stiff white dudes in a booth being like
oh yeah great naga yeah yeah john anak
yeah yeah man it was just so cool to see
it really made a
it made me feel like oh we're about to
be back yeah oh and did you see some
videos from
texas they have like the music fest like
edm fest oobi doobie or ubw whatever
it's called like with cascade
i saw videos we back yeah texas back
numbers are continuing to decline
in texas yeah and their numbers being
fully open
are lower than new york's numbers i
think michigan's numbers and a couple of
these
other these uh democratic states that
are not fully open yet it's like guys at
what point
i think we said this on the last part
but at what point are you not trusting
the science
data is right [ __ ] there you know
there's a saying from a pretty famous
scientist who said the definition of
insanity is trying the same thing over
and over again and expecting a different
result
that's what new york is doing so you say
trust science yeah you're doing the
exact thing the [ __ ] greatest
scientist ever said don't do yeah let's
keep doing the same [ __ ]
shut down shut down shut down it's a
[ __ ] baboon just a bunch of baboons
man
run in new york sauce nipple chip what
is it
chimp nipple sauce monkeys sauce monkeys
run in new york
governor cuomo is a sauce monkey uh bill
de blasio is another
sauce monkey and um cuomo happens to
have chimped
nipples so that's why he's a chimp
nippled [ __ ] sauce monkey yeah
and uh yeah he should be put in a zoo we
should put him in the [ __ ] bronx zoo
that's what we should do when he's done
with his term just stick him in the
bronx zoo with a bunch of other
chimpanzees yeah and let them have at it
dude
let's let them have at it just make some
[ __ ] meatballs and marinara for
the [ __ ] chimpanzees and the bronx
piece of [ __ ]
anyway what were the main fights you
thought from the night that were
significant
um i mean for me it was any time an
asian loss
uh no i for me it was thug rose's fight
and then it was
uh camaro's fight yeah yeah i mean you
saw did you see the full uriah hall
chris weidman fight
oh my god oh that was another thing that
happened
i mean chris weidman uh who's this uh
he's the first guy to dethrone anderson
silva
okay right and uh i was on stage when
this happened
he i literally was right before i went
on stage yeah thanks for everybody
coming out west palm it was amazing time
yeah um
and he he throws a leg kick
at your eye hall and then snaps his
[ __ ] leg in half
and you saw it happen in real time and
it was absolutely
devastating yeah the grossest part about
that yeah
he snaps his leg and steps and then
steps on his own
snapped rubber mesh
body down on the ground and it was the
scariest it was fascinating to look at i
saw a slow-mo of his face
and he doesn't realize he breaks until
he steps on he steps down yeah that
what is it called the adrenaline is just
going like you do feel pain but you
don't
i think you're in shock too yeah oh my
god
just unbelievable man yeah just i read a
stat that there's been three
like light breaks in ufc history and
he's been involved in two of them and
he's been involved too
yeah because anderson silva's leg broke
when he was
kicking him yeah i guess and it's just
you